oui bienvenue à gattaca 6000 somme au
rhône depuis cette semaine j'ai eu envie
de parler d'un sujet qui a pris toute la
place sur les médias sociaux
toute la place sur nos prix de nouvelles
et même je pense que mon algorithmes en
a été ébranlée c'est à de la discussion
sur les médias les forces nouvelles les
théories du complot et comment tout se
mélange les uns avec les autres
quelle information est vrai que les
formations et pose est ce que le média
et aux soldes de l'état est ce qu'il ya
des personnes qui ont une information
quand ils sont cachés dans leur sous sol
vous comprendrez que c'était un gros
débat une très grosse polémique sur les
médias sociaux
et là c'est pas de dire quel média
raison qu'elle me moquer le porteur
d'une vraie vérité c'est que je vois
aussi les effets de ce lot à sur les
membres de ma communauté je vois des
familles sont en train de discuter au
sujet de conversation qui habituellement
des modèles ou qui avait lieu pendant un
souper en famille mais maintenant que ça
devient vraiment des problématiques de
discussion et on va le voir aussi au
sein de communautés autochtones mais
aussi au sein de la province donc
pourquoi est ce que je voulais
absolument en parler puisque tout le
monde en parle déjà tout le monde a déjà
son opinion c'est que je voulais
profiter de mon privilège c'est à dire
d'avoir accès à un espace autochtone à
radio canada à travers le sport 7
octobre pour parler d'une expérience de
l'expérience que j'ai vécue justement à
travers les médias et comment je peux
comprendre que certaines personnes se
sentent visés par ma théorie du complot
comment des fois il faut créer des
médias qui sont indépendants les grands
médias mais aussi comment les grands
médias ont servi beaucoup de causes
comme celle de rideau noir par exemple
pourquoi j'en parle c'est qu'en 1990
quand pendant la crise d'oka quand notre
présentation dans les médias était
totale et gative qu'on n'entendait pas
les voix des premières nations
très souvent à paris ont bloqué des
routes et que si on n'avait pas eu
justement à l'année soit bonne semaine
pour faire un documentaire
l'information aurait extrêmement biaisé
et on pourrait croire à un complot
puisque nous avons continuellement à
l'information dans les médias et le
continent était ignorée donc on avance
dans le temps jusqu'en 2012 avec le
moment est bien là je commence à parler
de sujets et particulièrement d'un grand
complot canadie alors sur 100 ans via
lui des lois qui ont été créés pour nous
maintenant des réserves pour mettre nos
enfants dans des pensionnats pour
pouvoir effacer nos langue notre culture
et en plus mais il ya des problématiques
liées aux femmes assassinées et
disparues après avoir probablement aussi
beaucoup avec la relation qu'on a avec
les institutions telles que la police
les médecins mais vous pouvez comprendre
que quand je suis arrivé en 2012 avec
nos gros panier d'un complot canadien
beaucoup de gens y croyaient pas mais la
séance et quand je suis arrivé avec
beaucoup de mes collègues dans nos
moments un peu partout au canada avec
des effets extrêmement bien établis et
des faits qui ne pouvait pas être niée
bien sûr ça nous faisait beaucoup
d'attention sa demande ait aussi des
très patients vers des journalistes qui
n'avaient jamais eu à gérer les
questions sur les enjeux autochtones
donc pour eux qui couvre une multitude
de sujets il devait en même temps qu'il
devait digérer et présenter la nouvelle
devait se renseigner et s'éduquer sur la
question alors au début de la grogne moi
ce ne sont pas les grands médias qui ont
propagé le plus sa nouvelle ce sont les
médias et dépendants et on a beaucoup
compté sur les médias indépendants
puissent qu'ils avaient des voix et
c'était des voix souvent qui ont moins
nous quand je faisais une moins grande
[Musique]
ils peuvent atteindre moins en moins de
gens peut-être que radio-canada autres
tv
cependant ils sont intéressés par les
sujets beaucoup plus pointu et se sont
intéressés à la cause des programmations
ils ont commencé à partager les
informations et surtout quand j'ai pu
être vraiment témoins justement de ce
besoin de dualité en 2010 ça a été
pendant la crise étudiante
moi ce que j'ai coupé les nouvelles sur
la télévision
et j'avais mon ordinateur au vert sur
mon genou et c'est comme si je regardais
de deux angles totalement différent la
même question le même moment dans
l'histoire
comment elles étaient interprétés donc
il faut quand même être prudent parce
que les médias indépendants ont aussi
des fois des biais idéologique
donc selon tamedia excusez-moi
l'expression mais va être à gauche ou à
droite et bien les sujets qui vont une
couvert vont être couvert de façon
différente alors ses deux portes de
médias le bien ce sont quand même les
médecins indépendants qui ont permis de
faire voler la question des premières
nations qui l'a aidé moment jusqu'à ce
que les grands médias le prennent en
main et commence à en parler et leur
danse temps le ce qu'on voit c'est que
rêvée par rapport à l'acceptation qui a
eu une grande ignorance par rapport aux
enjeux autochtones
présentement le vaut aussi pour black
avec marc heures par rapport aux enjeux
des personnes sont assises et est qu'il
ya une transformation de ce grand quand
je vois ces grands dinosaures que le
média d'état mais cependant une fois que
l'information commence à être propulsé
par les grands médias
et bien vous n'avez plus à crier autant
on avait vu à ses vertus et sur
l'information
mais ce que le travail journalistique se
faisait une responsabilité
journalistique des journalistes doivent
s'assurer que leur information est vrai
que l'information est supporté par des
preuves
donc peu importe d'où vient le
journaliste on sait que des preuves
l'interprétation après nos questions
cependant présentement justement parce
que ce genre d'expérience qui ferait pas
de cas positifs avec les médias fait que
beaucoup de gens se détournent des
grands médias se détourne des médias
traditionnels ou des médias indépendants
et comment s'est créé leurs propres
médias c'est assez drôle puisque ça
devient un métier en soi qui doit
répondre un peu au même chose ça d'heure
les les blogs
les chroniqueurs qui doivent s'assurer
que l'information qui le porte est vrai
mais beaucoup de gens vraiment envie
chronique ondes et des blogs et ne
s'assure pas de la véracité ou ont des
croyances biaisé sur des sujets dont ils
ont des preuves qui elles mêmes sont
biaisées sur des sujets donc cette
responsabilité-là journalistique
n'existe plus vraiment avec les
personnalités à moins quand on décide de
venir les chercher pour leur faire
répondre à des faussetés donc pour faire
attention parce qu'on a quand même la
responsabilité en tant que citoyens de
ne pas porter atteinte à la réputation
de quelqu'un
tout ça pour dire que mon expérience
qu'elle soit 2
premier abord c'est à dire en tant que
citoyens qui ne se fait pas entendre
jusqu'à quelqu'un qui a accès aux grands
médias m'a fait vraiment voir comment on
peut se situer dans un camp ou l'autre
mais cependant quand on est souvent
enclavées dans une situation ce qu'on ne
sait pas écouter ou enclavées dans un
point de vue qui est tellement élevé
qu'on n'a pas l'image plus proche du
terrain et bien ça peut créer c'est le
moment où justement on se méfie des
grands métiers on se méfie des citoyens
qui ont un coût des opinions qui sort
des vidéos
cependant c'est important d'avoir un
point du détroit alors moi j'utilisais
beaucoup avec un bon moment aujourd'hui
encore une triangulation des
informations qu un grand média sort
quelque chose je m'en informer aussi
auprès de ce qui se passe chez le
citoyen puisqu'on et les médias sociaux
ils sont allés témoignages peuvent venir
directement des citoyens et j'ai aussi
informé auprès des médias indépendants
parce qu'ils vont avoir un point de vue
beaucoup plus libéré peut-être que les
grands médias et je vais faire une forme
de triangulation d'information qui peut
être beaucoup plus longue
sa double la recherche des foi de
certains sujets qui m'intéressent mais
ça vaut la peine parce que des fois j'en
parle sur un sujet que je vois tout de
suite au revoir je
il ya des petits bleus avaient des
petits drapeaux rouge qui s'allume et là
en faisant mes recherches parce que j'ai
une responsabilité d'informer
correctement aussi est bien là je
découvre canon n'y a pas de source pour
ça en est la recherche n'a pas été
approuvée vraiment où ils m'aiment pas
eu de recherches on est créé une fausse
recherche sur un site donc la
triangulation d'information j'étais en
utilisant toutes les sources
d'information me permets un peu comment
la géographie de me situer dans un
espace d'information et ça me permet de
faire marquer des fois dans des fausses
pistes d'information mais aussi ça me
permet de ne pas me fie uniquement à une
piste d'informations que l'on dit être
la seule piste adore les grands médias
mais par exemple ils ont tous les trois
leur force leur capacité et il devrait
aussi leur lot ridge donc vous
comprendrez
c'est très difficile d'avoir cette
discussion là en ce moment j'espère que
vous allez pas hésité à laisser des
commentaires positifs ou négatifs mais
toujours respectueux et n'hésitez pas à
partager cette vidéo parce qu'on n'a pas
fini d'en discuter c'est quand même une
problématique quand on n'est même pas
capable de s'écouter les uns les ont
alors merci pour votre attention je vous
souhaite une belle semaine